All right, so with that, there are lots
of other examples that I could come up
with and we could talk about.
But I think that, I think I've
sort of made the point here.
>> Yeah, that's really neat.
I mean, again, it feels,
not to be dissing on my homie,
King Solomon, but-
>> Namesake.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Isn't that what homie means?
>> In some, in Yiddish, yes.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, fine.
So, but again, if B is rich enough,
B is just buying the baby and not even
paying A appropriately for the baby.
>> Well, if B is rich enough,
B probably just bought a baby.
>> Yeah, but bought the baby for
the, [LAUGH] for
what, for the value, for
B's own value of the baby.
>> So, it has to be the case that V real
is greater than V fake for all of this.
>> Yeah.
>> But let's just say it is.
And if it's not, then we'll
come up with some other design.
And actually, by the way,
there are mechanisms for
solving this where it may be the case
that fake's greater than real, but
you sort of limit the possible
values that each might get,
you kind of think there's
like a distribution of them.
And there are clever things that you
can do to sort of make this work.
But well beyond the scope of this single
slide, which we've done all of this on
one slide, so it's well beyond-
>> All of this and a little more.
>> Yeah, there's just no
more room on the slide, so
I can't talk about it anymore.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So,
I think speaking of game theory and
true values, we have a problem.
>> All right, what's the problem?
>> The problem we have is that we've now
come to the part of the lesson where we
have to say what have we learned, and
one of us drives and the other talks.
>> Great.
>> But
we both did things in this lesson.
>> So, I'm going to say that
we kept switching turns in
order to make parity work.
You should do the what have we learned.